I'm going to tell you about the most
amazing machines in the world and what
we can now do with that proteins some of
which you see inside a cell here carry
out essentially all the important
functions in our bodies proteins digest
your food contract your muscles fire
your neurons and power your immune
system everything that happens in
biology almost happens because of
proteins proteins are linear chains of
building blocks called amino acids
nature uses an alphabet of 20 amino
acids some which have names you may have
heard of in this picture for scale each
bump is an atom chemical forces between
the amino acids cause these long stringy
molecules to fold up into unique
three-dimensional structures the folding
process while it looks random is in fact
very precise each protein folds to its
characteristic shape each time and the
folding process takes just a fraction of
a second and it's the shapes of proteins
which enable them to carry out their
remarkable biological functions for
example hemoglobin has a shape in the
lungs perfectly suited for binding a
molecule of oxygen when hemoglobin moves
to your muscle the shape changes
slightly and the oxygen comes out the
shapes of proteins and hence their
remarkable functions are completely
specified by the sequence of amino acids
in the protein chain in this picture
each letter on top is an amino acid
where do these sequences come from the
genes in your genome specify these amino
acid sequences of your proteins each
gene encodes the amino acid sequence of
a single protein the translation between
these amino acid sequences
and the structures and functions of
proteins is known as the protein folding
problem it's a very hard problem these
are so many different shapes a protein
can adopt because of this complexity
humans have only been able to harness
the power of proteins by making very
small changes to the amino acid
sequences of the proteins we found in
nature this is similar to the process
that our stone-age ancestors used to
make tools and other implements from the
sticks and stones that we found in the
world around us but humans did not learn
to fly by modifying birds instead
scientists inspired by birds uncovered
the principles of aerodynamics Engineers
then use those principles to design
custom flying machines in the similar
way we've been working for a number of
years to uncover the fundamental
principles of protein folding and
encoding those principles in the
computer program called Rosetta we've
made a breakthrough in recent years we
can now design completely new proteins
from scratch on the computer once we've
designed the new protein we encode its
amino acid sequence in a synthetic gene
we have to make a synthetic gene because
since the protein is completely new
there's no gene in any organism on earth
which currently exists that encodes it
our advances in in understanding protein
folding and how to design proteins
coupled with the decreasing cost of gene
synthesis and the Moore's Law increase
in computing power now enable us to
design tens of thousands of new proteins
with new shapes and new functions on the
computer encode and encode each one of
those is in a synthetic gene once we
have those synthetic genes we put them
into bacteria to program to make them to
make these brand new proteins weak then
extract the proteins and determine
whether they function as we design them
to and whether they're safe it
exciting to be able to make new proteins
because despite the diversity in nature
evolution has only sampled a tiny
fraction of the total number of proteins
possible I told you that nature uses an
alphabet of 20 amino acids and a typical
protein is a chain of about a hundred
amino acids so the total number of
possibilities is twenty times twenty
times twenty a hundred times which is a
number on the order of ten to the
hundred thirtieth power which is
enormous li more than the total number
of proteins which have existed since
life on earth began
and it's this unimaginably large space
we can now explore using computational
protein design now the proteins that
exist on earth evolved to solve the
problems faced by natural evolution for
example replicating the genome but we
faced new challenges today we live
longer so new diseases are important
we're heating up and polluting the
planet so we face a whole host of
ecological challenges if we had a
million years to wait new proteins might
evolve to solve those challenges but we
don't have millions of years to wait
instead with computational protein
design we can design new sweet new
proteins to address these challenges
today our audacious idea is to bring
biology out of the Stone Age through
technological revolution in protein
design we've already shown that we can
design new proteins with new shapes and
functions for example vaccines work by
stimulating your immune system to make a
strong response against a pathogen to
make better vaccines we've designed
protein particles to which we confuse
proteins from pathogens like this blue
protein here from the respiratory virus
RSV to make vaccine candidates that are
literally bristling with the viral
protein we find that such vaccine
candidates produce a much stronger
immune response to the virus than any
previous vaccines that have been tested
the
important because RSV is currently one
of the leading causes of infant
mortality worldwide we've also designed
new proteins to break down gluten in
your stomach for celiac disease and
other proteins to stimulate your immune
system to fight cancer these advances
are the beginning of the protein design
revolution we've been inspired by a
previous technological revolution the
digital revolution which took place in
large part due to advances in one place
Bell Laboratories Bell Labs was a place
with an open collaborative environment
and was able to attract top talent from
around the world and this led to a
remarkable string of innovations the
transistor the laser satellite
communication and the foundations of the
Internet our goal is to build the bell
laboratories of protein design we are
seeking to attract talented scientists
from around the world to accelerate a
protein design revolution and we'll be
focusing on five Grand Challenges first
by taking proteins from flu strains from
around the world and putting them on top
of the design protein particles I just
showed you earlier
we aim to make a universal flu vaccine
one shot of which gives a lifetime of
protection against the flu the ability
design
the Billy's design new vaccines on the
computer is important both to protect
against natural flu epidemics and in
addition intentional acts of
bioterrorism second we're going far
beyond nature's limited alphabet of just
20 amino acids to design new therapeutic
candidates for conditions such as
chronic pain using an alphabet of
thousands of amino acids third we're
building advanced delivery vehicles to
target existing medications exactly
where they need to go in the body for
example chemotherapy to a tumor or gene
therapies to the tissue where gene
repair needs to take place fourth we're
designing smart therapeutics that can do
calculations within the body and go far
beyond current medicines which are
really blunt instruments for example to
target a small subset of immune cells
responsible for an autoimmune disorder
and distinguish them from the vast
majority of healthy immune cells finally
inspired by remarkable biological
materials such as silk abalone shell
tooth and others were designing new
protein based materials to address
challenges in energy and ecological
issues to do all this we're growing our
Institute where we seek to attract
energetic talented and diverse
scientists from around the world at all
career stages to join us you can also
participate in the protein design
revolution through our online folding
game folding and design game fold it and
through our distributed computing
project Rosetta at home which you can
join from your laptop or your Android
smartphone making the world a better
place through protein design is my
life's work
I'm so excited about what we can do
together I hope you'll join us and thank
you
[Music]